خسائر متزايده في الارواح والاملاك
والاقتصاد سببه الزلزال المدمر الذي اصاب
سوريا الاسبوع الماضي ليضيف معاناه اضافيه
لاقتصاد انهكتته صراعات سياسيه لاكثر من
12 عاما وما زالت مستمره غياب البيانات
الرسميه والشفافيه واتساع رقعه تاثير
الزلزال بين مناطق خاضعه للنظام واخرى
للمعارضه يزيدان من صعوبه تقدير حجم
الاضرار والتي تجاوزت بالمجمل عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات
وحول الخسائر الماديه افادت منظمه الخوه
البيضاء بان اكثر من 300 وخمسه وسبعين
مبنى انهار كليا واكثر من 1200 مبنى انهار
جزئيا كما تصدعت الاف المباني الاخرى كما
اصاب زلزال اقتصاد سوريا في مقتل خاصه انه
ضرب اربعه محافظات مسؤوله عن اكثر من ثلث
اقتصاد البلاد
فمحافظه حلب المتاثره الاكبر من الزلزال
مسؤوله عن اكثر من 16% من اقتصاد سوريا
فيما تمثل محافظه حماه المرتبه الخامسه
بنسبه مساهمه في الاقتصاد السوري بما يصل
الى تسعه في المئه ثم اللاذقيه في المرتبه
السادسه بسبعه فاصل ثمانيه في المئه
مساهمه بالاقتصاد اما محافظه ادلب التي
تنقسم السيطره فيها بين النظام والمعارضه
والمتاثره بالزلزال تصل مساهمتها في
الاقتصاد الى 2.7%
انقسام الوضع السياسي في سوريا يزيد من
معاناه المتاثرين بالزلزال المدمر اعاده
الاعمار على الجانب السوري خاصه في
المناطق التي تخضع للمعارضه والتي في
الاصل تضم مئات الالاف من المهجرين ستكون
الاصعب في غياب رقابه حكوميه وهرب من
المسؤوليه من المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه
شادي الزعيم العربيه